to india now where the kovid 19 caseload
continues to rise
at a record pace on friday alone the
country reported over 400
000 new infections and nearly 4 000
deaths
actual numbers appeared to be much
higher still international aid is
starting to trickle in but for many in a
country
ravaged by the pandemic that helping
hand comes too late
this is the bitter reality of india's
kobed emergency
nearly a quarter of a million lives lost
as the bodies mount the crematoria
struggle to cope
and there's no end in sight to this
crisis
hospitals too are buckling under the
pressure
[Music]
there's a lack of beds and a lack of
staff
but the one crucial thing that has made
this second wave different
and more devastating than last year's
emergency
is a lack of oxygen
this time male problem is not the
numbers but the complications
the patient in last year only 10 to 20
percent required oxygen around only five
percent required ico advances
but this time more than 50 percent now
60 percent are
requiring oxygen these people could have
a greater chance of surviving the crisis
they're in the queue to be vaccinated
but the rollout has been slow
and jabs are in short supply
international aid has begun pouring into
india
supplies of medical equipment are now
arriving from all over
as other countries wake up to the scale
of the tragedy
and the threat it could pose to their
own populations
but the aid cannot arrive quick enough
to slow down the dying
families are helpless as their loved
ones succumb to what researchers say
is a far more infectious strain of the
virus
but there's anger too
with some asking why the government has
decided to allow election rallies
and other large events
call it the system or government or
whatever was it necessary to conduct
elections right now
for this family and countless others
that question
comes too late well we can bring in dw's
delhi bureau chief emery to chima now
amrita
what's the situation today
well anthony to some extent the numbers
speak for themselves another huge record
rise in new infections
now obviously their virus is on the
rampage across the country
in some areas though there's some signs
of improvement delhi for example
saw a slight drop in numbers in the past
24 hours
and also mumbai there seemed to be signs
of improvement there so these two cities
were the hardest hit
but the virus has spiked in other parts
of the country
states in the south and in the east and
we've heard of your report about
election rallies
in fact some of the states where
elections were held recently have seen a
huge
surge but most worrying at the moment is
actually
news coming out of rural areas for
example in the northern state of uttar
pradesh
people say the situation there is dire
and infections are really going up
amrita we hear that international aid is
arriving is it yet making a difference
on the ground though
if it's reaching the people who need it
yes it's making a difference
germany for example sent a huge
consignment uh yesterday and today
and there is that is a mobile oxygen
generation
plant now this is going to be assembled
and become operational in the next few
days
a team has come along from the
bundeswehr the medical team which will
set up this uh
oxygen uh plant as well as train local
people here to use it
and the capacity it has anthony is it
can generate
400 000 liters of oxygen a day
now for people who have access to that
kind of oxygen in the medical facility
where it's being deployed
in the outskirts of delhi it's a huge
game
outside of those particular examples
what's the latest on oxygen supplies
across the country
are there any signs of relief and is it
reaching those
who need it i think there's still a big
oxygen
crunch in the country and if you also
think about the scale of this pandemic
the need for oxygen has gone up
seven-fold
in the last few weeks so there are
cities like delhi which say they're
simply not getting enough they want 700
metric tons
they have less than half in the south
kerala for example
had an oxygen surplus and now it's
struggling people were hearing stories
from rajasthan or
the city of chennai in in southern india
where people had died in hospitals when
oxygen ran out
and bangalore or bengaluru is the latest
hotspot where we are getting distressed
calls
about you know how oxygen is in very
short supply
so the prime minister had a meeting with
his ministers and he's hoping
that some of these systemic problems and
some of them what people are calling
we need to audit the supplies of oxygen
are tackled with
delhi bureau chief amrita chima many
thanks
you